Es ist nicht nur uralt, sondern auch mit keinem
anderen Lebewesen vergleichbar!
In Kanada hat eine Forscherin jetzt in einer
Erdprobe einen bisher nicht bekannten Organismus
entdeckt.
Fest steht: Das Urwesen lässt sich keinem
unserer Entwicklungszweige zuordnen.
Forschungsteams rätseln jetzt, ob es sich
um eine Art Superorganismus handelt.
Alles, was ihr zu dieser sensationellen Entdeckung
wissen müsst, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction, hier gibt es täglich mindblowing
Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal, nur dann
verpasst ihr kein Video. herzlich willkommen!
Sein Name lautet Hemimastix kukwesjijk – abgeleitet
von dem Begriff “Kukwes”.
Und der wiederum steht für einen Oger, also
Unhold, der sehr gierig und haarig ist und
aus der Mythologie nordamerikanischer Indianer
stammt (Mi'kmaq).
Dieses Urwesen, das nach Ansicht des kanadischen
Forschungsteams nicht nur wie solch ein “Unhold”
aussieht, sondern sich aus so benimmt, war
bisher völlig unbekannt.
Und unter dem Mikroskop sieht es wirklich
ziemlich gruselig aus: Ein Einzeller, der
etwa zwei hundertstel Millimeter lang ist
und der mit Hilfe seiner Flagellen vorankommt
– und das eher unkoordiniert.
Als Flagellen werden die kleinen Härchen
bezeichnet, die an den Seiten hervorstehen.
Auf seinem Speiseplan des frisch entdeckten
Mikroorganismus stehen kleine Mikroben.
Und die erbeutet er sich ziemlich geschickt
mit seinen Extrusomen.
Damit sind kleine Harpunen gemeint, mit denen
er seine Beute beschießt und zu sich heranzieht,
um sie dann zu verspeisen.
Und obwohl diese Entdeckung wirklich spektakulär
ist, ist es keineswegs so, dass nach diesem
mysteriösen Wesen lange gesucht wurde!
Eigentlich war es sogar purer Zufall, dass
der Mini-Organismus entdeckt werden konnte
– gepaart mit dem guten Forscher-Instinkt
der kanadischen Evolutionsbiologin Yana Eglit.
Sie hatte 2016 bei einer Wanderung in Nova
Scotia, einer ostkanadischen Provinz, den
richtigen Riecher und nahm Erdproben mit.
Als sie diese dann im Labor untersuchte, konnte
sie ihren Augen kaum trauen.
Seltene Urwesen trieben sich in den Proben
herum.
Konkret nämlich eukaryotische Protisten.
Eukaryotisch bedeutet, dass die Wesen über
komplexe Zellen verfügen, eben so wie wir
Menschen.
Doch die Spezies gehört weder zu den Pilzen,
Pflanzen noch Tieren.
Das ist mit dem Begriff “Protist” gemeint.
Das neu entdeckte Urwesen ist übrigens einzellig;
so wie die meisten Protisten.
Yana Eglit isolierte sie, züchtete Nahrung
für die Mikroorganismen und so gelang ihr
irgendwann das Unmögliche: Sie ist tatsächlich
der erste Mensch, der es geschafft hat, diesen
Einzeller dann auch noch zu kultivieren.
Ihn so quasi zur ihrem “Haustier” zu machen;
natürlich nur im übertragenen Sinn :) Genetische
Analysen standen als erstes mit auf dem Plan.
Damit wollte das Forschungsteam herausfinden,
wie sich Hemimastix kukwesjij entwickelt haben
und mit wem sie verwandt sind.
Dafür wurde eine äußerst neue und innovative
Technik genutzt.
Der Name: “Single Cell Transcriptonomics”.
Mit dieser Methode können genetische Informationen
sequenziert werden und die Technik ist sogar
bei Zellen möglich, die viermal kleiner sind
als ein einzelner menschlicher Haarstrang.
Das Besondere hierbei ist, dass man die gewünschten
Infos aus zwei oder vier Zellen erhalten kann
anstatt wie bei Standardverfahren Millionen
von Zellen zu benötigen.
Und mit DIESEM Ergebnis hatte wirklich niemand
gerechnet.
Das Urwesen lässt sich tatsächlich keinem
unserer Entwicklungszweige zuordnen.
Alstair Simpson, einer der beteiligten Forscher
der kanadischen Dalhousie University, sagt:
“Diese Entdeckung lässt uns den Baum des
Lebens quasi neu zeichnen - und zwar an seiner
tiefsten Stelle.
Außerdem eröffnet uns die Entdeckung die
Möglichkeit, die Evolution und den Ursprung
komplexer Zellen neu zu verstehen - und zwar
lange, bevor es überhaupt Tiere und Pflanzen
auf der Erde gab”.
Das Forschungsteam geht jetzt davon, dass
sich ein gemeinsamer Vorfahr weit zurück
in der Vergangenheit finden lässt, also vor
etwa einer Milliarde Jahre!!!
Also unglaubliche 500 Millionen Jahre, bevor
sich die ersten Tiere entwickelten.
Doch klar ist das bisher noch nicht.
Zunächst soll jetzt erst einmal das komplette
Genom sequenziert werden, dazu heißt es in
der Studie: “"Das ist eine ganz neue Möglichkeit,
um die Entwicklung von komplexen Zellen und
deren Ursprünge zu erforschen”.
Das Forschungsteam jedenfalls ist immer noch
fassungslos über seinen eigenen Erfolg.
Dazu Simpsons: "Dass sich solch eine Lebensform
buchstäblich unter unseren Füßen verstecken
könnte, macht uns deutlich, wie wenig wir
noch über die Vielfalt des Lebens auf der
Erde wissen."
Da denken wir nur im Weltraum können wir
wirklich neues Bahnbrehchendes entdecken,
dabei kann es sich auch direkt unter unseren
Füßen befinden.
Wow.
Wenn ihr absolut nichts von Clixoom Science
& Fiction verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
auch den englischen Kanal, denn nur dann verpasst
ihr auch keine Videopremiere, denn die gibt
es genauso da.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Und weiter geht es hier mit: Frankenstein's
heirs: Researchers create human-rat hybrid
beings.
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned.